self-discipline is one of the biggest
things that will change your life
forever why because if you don't have
control over yourself you will forever
be a slave to your emotions your desires
and your passions people seem to have
less and less self control and you can
see the effect of it all over the world
to set yourself apart and start to think
different because if you can't master
your thoughts how are you going to
master your actions and your life
if you want to overcome most of the
challenges that this life throws at you
and achieve your goals you need to
change yourself first but how do you do
that one of the best things that will
help you to do it is self discipline
it's about controlling your impulses
your desires while staying focused on
what needs to be done to achieve your
goals it might be hard at times yes of
course nothing is easy in this world but
the results will be priceless
you alone are responsible for your life
no excuses all success in life doesn't
just happen
it starts with self-discipline and is
the ability to force yourself to do
something every day in spite of how you
feel until it becomes a habit
and the key to do that is to understand
the difference of what you want now
right now in your life how you feel and
what you want most out of life
and don't just wish for success but work
for it and what you're putting today is
what you will receive tomorrow because
you will reap what you sow to start
today discipline yourself by setting
clear goals and work for it every day
even if you don't feel like it
remember self-discipline starts with you
[Music]